بطبيعه الحال هي طبعا اصيبت بجروح عمليا
الادعاء من قبل
المصادر العسكريه الاسرائيليه بانها
ركضت نحو الجنود وكانت تحمل سكينه ارادت
طعن احد الجنود واطلقت عليها النار لم
نتاكد من مصادر اخرى من صحه هذا
الادعاء لكن في المجمل طبعا فقط اشير الى
ان المقاتلات التي رايناها قبل قليل هي
ليست فوق القدس وانما فوق المنطقه
الحدوديه مع قطاع غزه نحن نتواجد هنا منذ
بعض الوقت ودائما هناك مقاتلات تحلق في
هذه المنطقه في ظل التوتر الحاصل على جبهه
قطاع غزه الاجواء تبدو هادئه نسبيا هذا
الصباح بعد تبادل القصف بعد اطلاق الغارات
الاسرائيليه التي عاقبت اطلاق الصواريخ
الفلسطينيه لكن هذا التصعيد كان حقيقه
متوقعا بعدما حتل حصل عفوا في
فصائل الفلسطينيه اعلنت بان هذه المجزره
ستلاقي ردا واطلقت الصواريخ فقط للتذكير
هذا التصاعد في التصعيد انجاز التعبير على
كافه الجبهات وصولا الى التصعيد على جبهه
قطاع غزه هذا الشهر يعني في خلال الشهر
الاخير اطلق ثلاثه 33 صاروخا من قطاع غزه
يعني هذا يكاد يكون غير مسبوق هناك قصف
متقطع طوال الوقت كلما جرى تصعيد في الضفه
في مخيم جنين في مناطق اخرى تنطق صواريخ
وتشنغارات اسرائيليه في المقابل في اطار
ماباتا يعرف بوحده الساحات عمليا عبد
الحفيظ اعود اليك وكيف تبدو تداعيات ما
حدث يوم امس في نابلس على المشهد في هذه
المدينه
نعم هناك اضراب شامل يعم مختلف المناطق
الفلسطينيه والمدن الفلسطينيه يشمل
الاضراب المدارس والمؤسسات الرسميه او
المؤسسات الخاصه والمواصلات وكل شيء وذلك
استنكارًا للهجوم الاسرائيلي على مدينه
نابلس والذي ادى الى يعني مقتل احد عشر
فلسطينيا اضافه الى فلسطين اخر ايضا يعني
توفي متاثرا بجراحه التي كان قد اصيب فيها
في مدينه جنين قبل اسبوعين بذلك يرتفع عدد
الضحايا الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام
الى اكثر من 65 فلسطينيين وزاره الصحه
تقول ان هذا رقم مهول لم يشهده
الفلسطينيون منذ اكثر من 15 عاما وبالتالي
هذا مؤشر خطير على هذا التصعيد الكبير
اضافه لاضراب الشامل الذي يعم مختلف في
المناطق الفلسطينيه هناك دعوات ايضا من
الفصائل لتسيير تظاهرات ومسيرات نحو نقاط
التماس المختلفه ضفه الغربيه والتي شهدت
ايضا هذه الضفه الغربيه هذه الليله عده
عمليات اطلاق نار وخصوصا في حجز قلنديا
شمال مدينه القدس وايضا بالقرب من مدينه
الطولكرم هناك دعوات من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه ومن اجنحه مسلحه ومجموعات
مسلحه لتفعيل موضوع العمليات وخصوصا
العمليات الفرديه او عمليات اطلاق النار
التي تستهدف يعني اهداف اسرائيليه سواء في
الضفه الغربيه او في الداخل طيب انقل هذه
النقطه ايضا الى زياده يعني زياد اقتحام
نابلس امس يذكرنا
بالاقتحام الاسرائيلي الاخير لمخيم جنين
وما نجم عنه ايضا من عمليات فلسطينيه في
الداخل الاسرائيلي هل انعكست احداث الامس
بشكل واضح على الوضع الامني في المناطق
الاسرائيليه وتحدث عن القدس على سبيل
المثال
هذا صحيح يعني نحن نبدو في اجواء تشبه الى
حد ما الاجواء التي سادت عشيه الحرب
الاخيره التي شنت في رمضان الماضي على
قطاع غزه
بهذا المعنى هذا صحيح جدا اسرائيل تصاعد
الاقتحامات والاغتيالات وقتل الفلسطينيين
في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله ما يقود
الى اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه ومن ثم
غارات ومن ثم موجه مما يسمى بالعمليات
الفرديه ان كان في القدس عمليا الشرقيه
المحتله او الغربيه او حتى في الداخل
الاسرائيلي هذه الامور تتكرر طوال الوقت
عمليا خاصه عندما تقوم اسرائيل بعمليات
فيها تقتل فيها الكثير من الفلسطينيين كما
حدث بالامس في نابلس هذا الامر مرشح
للاستمرار هناك تقديرات في اسرائيل بان
الامور الى تصاعد وصولا الى شهر رمضان
نهايه الشهر
المقبل عمليا لانه ايضا سيتزامن مع عيد
لليهود عيد الفصح اليهودي والتوتر في
منطقه الاقصى يعني الامور تبدو وكانها
تعيد نفسها الى حد ما رغم ان اسرائيل كانت
تعاهدت للامريكيين بتخفيف وطاه العمليات
ربما في محاوله لمنع استصدار قرار
والتصويت عليه ادانه للمستوطنات في مجلس
الامن والاكتفاء ببيان رئاسي لكن غداه ذلك
عمليا راينا بانها قامت بمجزره في نابلس
عبد الحفيظ كيف يبدو المشهد في المعابر
الواصله بين الضفه الغربيه
والمناطق الاسرائيليه ايضا مدى شده وجديه
هذه الاجراءات وتاثيراتها ايضا
وانعكاساتها على سكان الضفه
نعم منذ عام تقريبا منذ ان اطلقت اسرائيل
عمليه كاسره الامواج ونحن نشهد تجديدات
كبيره على المعابر على الحواجز داخل الضفه
الغربيه الامر احمد فقط يعني غير مرتبط
فقط بالمعابر بين الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل
وايضا حتى داخل الضفه الغربيه هناك حواجز
هناك تجديدات
اسرائيل كل بضعه الشرطه تعلن عن نشر كتائب
جديده ووحدات جديده من الجيش الاسرائيلي
داخل الضفه الغربيه على الحواجز على تخوم
المستوطنات عمليا منذ ان قدمت هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي توصف بالاكثر تشددا ونحن
نشهد تغييرات كبيره على الارض سواء من
ناحيه الاقتحامات الواسعه للمدن سقوط هذا
العدد الكبير من الضحايا وايضا امور اخرى
الى ذات علاقه بتكثيف هدم المنازل تكثيف
بناء المستوطنات ايضا حتى داخل السجون
السجون تغلي هناك العديد من الاجراءات
الاسرائيليه التي اتخذت بحق الاسرى وهناك
تهديدات خوض اضراب عن الطعام وبالتالي
الامور بشكل عام ميدانيا متوتره للغايه
منذ بدايه هذا العام ومنذ قدوم هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده زياد
بالتاكيد الجميع تابعه للتوترات الاخيره
داخل اسرائيل على خلفيه القرارات
الاسرائيليه التي تنفذها الحكومه اليمنيه
الجديده هل تمثل مثل هذه العمليات سواء في
نابلس او الضربات التي نفذت اليوم في غزه
هل تمثل مخرجا
للحكومه الاسرائيليه او وسيله للفت
الانتباه الى
اتجاهات اخرى غير سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
يقول العارفون في شان الاسرائيلي انه
بالفعل ان نتنياهو يبحث عن تغيير العنوان
الوحيد تقريبا الذي يسيطر تماما على
الشارع الاسرائيلي وهو المعركه
الحاميه على ما بدا يسمى بالانقلاب على
نظام القضاء في اسرائيل
بحسب خطه
حكومه نتنياهو يكون ذلك عاده
بالتصعيد الامني هذا امر ليس جديدا على
المشهد الاسرائيلي حدث في السابق وما زال
يحدث بطبيعه الحال عندما يكون هناك توتر
امني او عسكري في اسرائيل فهو يعني ياخذ
الاهتمام من الشارع
الاسرائيلي تماما كما دائما التلويح
بالخطر الداهم الخارجي ايران والنووي وما
الى ذلك هذا قد يكون منطقيا من حيث الطرح
وسنكون في متابعه لاي تفاصيل جديده شكرا
لكم الزميلين من مدينه عسقلان كنت معنا
مراسله العربيه زياد حلبي ومن رام الله
كنت معنا مراسله العربيه عبد الحفيظ جعوان
شكرا جزيلا لكما